- In this video, we're
gonna learn how to use
the software called ImageJ.
And the first thing you need
to do is go to this website
written here to access
the software online.
We're gonna use a file,
picture of a hair follicle
to demonstrate how to
open an image in ImageJ
and stack some different layers of images
into one image, add color,
and adjust the brightness
and contrast in these images.
And so what you can do
is just take the file
and drag it into the window.
And when you drop it,
the file should open.
Oh, there it is.
So here you see a stacked
image for four channels
that we took with the
florescence microscope,
and each channel was taken
with a different marker.
And you can see here
that there's a scroll bar
at the bottom showing,
now it's showing just one of the channels.
And if you scroll, you can see
all the different channels.
So in this picture, you
have a total of four.
And so now each channel
shows you individually
what the images look like.
But what we wanna do is see
all of the channels together
and assign them different colors.
And the one quick way
to do this is to go here
in the image tab under color,
and click make composite.
So once you do that,
you can see here now that all
four channels are visible,
each of them assigned
with a different color.
So you see red, green, blue, and white.
So for us to see all of these channels,
if you can, so we can
individually turn them
on and off, can go back to image, color,
and click on channels tool.
Once you do with that
this window will appear.
And it shows you like
the four channels here.
So the first channel is,
if we turn it on and off,
you can see that it's the red channel.
And channel two is the green one,
channel three is the blue one,
and channel four is the white one.
And so you can play with these channels,
turn them on and off.
For example, you could
only see channel one,
then you can see only the
red, and see channel one
and two only, you only see red and green.
And so we can turn them
on and off like that.
So now what we want to do
is to adjust the brightness
and contrast of different channels.
And so now you go here to image, adjust,
and here there's some brightness contrast.
So with scientific images,
normally we actually
don't adjust brightness
and contrast per se,
but rather the minimum
and the maximum signal
that we allow to be visible in the image.
And so you can see here
that there's a histogram
of a color red, indicating that
you are in the red channel.
So for example, when we
move across channels,
we can for example, the second channel,
we know it's the green one,
you can see that this changes as well.
And you move again.
Now we're in the blue
channel, this changes as well.
So let's say we want to make
the red channel brighter.
So first we go to the correct channel,
and you will see here again the color.
We're in the red channel and to adjust,
to make it brighter, what you can do
is decrease the maximum here.
And so, as you move along,
you can see their red getting
brighter and brighter,
and like right here, like,
we're at a very saturated point,
which usually you don't want
with scientific imaging.
So maybe we'll just move it down to here.
And so, if you want to see it clearer
you can just turn off the other channels,
and then you can do the same thing.
You can adjust it here.
So now let's try to do it
in a different channel, say the green one.
And so I have to move
again, the channel here,
and now you're at the green one.
If you want to make it brighter again,
just move it, the maximum down.
Now you start to see that actually
there's background signal here.
Where there's actually no real signal,
but there's some auto fluorescence.
And so sometimes what you
want to do is to remove
that background signal to
make the image look nicer.
And for that to happen, now we adjust,
instead, the minimum, you
can increase the minimum,
such that you don't see the
background signal anymore.
Like that, for example.
And then we can put
back the other channels,
and now you see how the
different channels interact.
So right now you see that
the blue is very dim,
so we can adjust that too.
Go to the blue channel,
and just decrease the maximum
to increase the signal.
And now you can actually see
the blue dots up here in.
And so let's say you don't like
the colors of these images.
So say I wanna, for example,
the last channel, which is white here,
it's actually a nuclear
stain, which typically
in most scientific
displays is shown as blue.
And so let's say we want
to change this into blue,
but actually we know that
channel three is already blue.
So say we want to switch their colors.
Let's making the channel
three white instead.
So now we're in channel
three, you can see here
because it's the blue
channel and yes, the third.
In here.
Just go here, to more,
and here you can see the different colors
that you can put them in.
And now we're going to
change them to white,
which is actually called grays here.
So just click that, and
you see now suddenly
the blues became white.
And then now, but we now
we have two white channels
channel three and channel four.
So now I want to switch
channel four into blue.
So you can just go with the
channel four, the last one here
in the scroll bar, and then
do the same thing, click blue.
And now that became blue.
But now that's quite dim actually.
So now we can adjust that
again to increase the CML
so we can see them naturally.
Now the white, because white
looks brighter to the eye.
I think it's a bit too bright now.
So let's just decrease
that to make it look nicer.
So let's say we're happy with this image.
So what you want to do,
if you save it just as is,
it will actually not change anything.
It will still save as the same exact file
that you started with.
So what you want to do
to save the colored image
is just go to image,
color, and stack to RGB.
This will compile all the colors
together in one flat image.
And so now you have this new file,
which is the hair follicle RGB,
but actually what you see here,
let's just move that out of the way,
that you don't have the scroll bar here,
because all the channels
are merged together.
And so, for example, if you just go here,
you see that the brightness
contrast only has one thing.
And if you move that around
it just adjust all the colors together.
So, if you're happy with this
image now you can save it.
Go to file, save as TIF,
and you can change the name.
Let's see.
No access to the TIF.
So let's just remove that.
Press okay.
And that should save in your computer.
So I'm just going to open it.
So if we go back here
to the original image,
if you click on that and
just try to preview it
in your computer.
Well, it's loading.
You see that actually,
you don't see anything
because this image has not been processed.
You cannot really see it with
regular viewing applications,
like the one that you see here.
But now if we go to the new one,
which we just downloaded.
Which is here, double click
that, just to view it,
now you can actually see it.
And then this, you can
use in any application
like PowerPoint, or whichever you want.
So yeah, now you know
how to adjust the colors
and the brightness of images,
especially with scientific
images that are usually a stack
of multiple colors in this
software called ImageJ.